thank you
the end of the road begins dang that is
a sad sentence for all of us who've been
following Dom and the fast crew for the
last 20 something years and I gotta say
we have questions as we gear up for the
first of the final two chapters in This
Global franchise like one who's the
villain and what does he want two what
characters are back and who's new and
three who is not making it out alive so
my family fast 10 your seat belts
because this is everything you need to
know before you go
[Applause]
so before we take a drive down memory
lane we want to give a shout out to all
the newer folks you may be asking
yourself okay what is the fast Saga all
about it's already too late okay Dom
settle down it's quite simple really
it's about the cars fast cars romances
romances flag girls flag girls black
girls but most importantly family Don
Toretto and his family have been
outwitting outgrading and outshifting
their foes for nine films now so getting
up to speed with our heroes might seem
like a bit of an impossible task to
anyone who hasn't kept up with the
series it's okay we forgive you I smell
skanks staying true to character Letty
but let's rewind to the film that
started it all the Fast and the Furious
this was our first introduction to the
world of street racing and The Lovable
crew Through The Eyes of undercover cop
Brian O'Connor played by the late great
Paul Walker as he fell in love with the
people and underground world of fast
cars we fell in love right alongside him
and we've been hooked ever since you
know the best decision I ever made is
stepping into the store
buying that first sandwich and listen
we'd love to do a deep dive into all the
films leading up to fast 10 but because
we don't have you know 20 years let's
punch the Nos and speed things up a
little from what we've seen in the fast
10 trailers it looks like the movie
leans heavily on The Fast Five climax
where Dom and Brian obliterate the
film's Baddie Brazilian drug lord Hernan
Reyes using a giant safe
ouch turns out hernan's son Dante played
by Jason Momoa who looks like he's
having a ball emerges from the shadows
as the most lethal opponent the crew
will ever face fueled by Blood Revenge
as he seeks to destroy Dom and his
family after the events of Fast Five
it's revealed in Fast and Furious 6 at
the accidental death of beloved
character hanlu who has the greatest
hair in the franchise at the end of
Tokyo Drift was actually a Murder By
none other than Jason Statham's Deckard
Shaw who is a former MI6 agent turn
mercenary and Furious Evans villain but
what the f I mean is that Han and Decker
teaming up what is happening if you're
confused let me uncross your wires so
Han's death was actually actually faked
by government agent Mr Nobody played by
Kurt Russell who hired Han to steal some
dangerous Tech all that to say Han shows
up definitely alive and not exploded in
F9 surprising Dom Roman tej etc etc who
still thought he was dead we're feeling
it too ludicrous we're feeling it too
but why is batty Deckard Shaw looking
heroic well let's just say that fast
Saga has a thing for turning some of
their villains into the good-ish guys so
in the eighth installment the fate of
the Furious deckardshaw actually ends up
saving the life of Dom's infant son from
The Notorious cyber terrorist Cipher
played by none other than Charlize
Theron oh what's that you didn't know
Dom was a daddy well neither did he
surprise Dom you are the father all this
fuss over you okay so back to Cipher by
the looks of it she's still hanging
around in fast X and annoying the crew
especially Letty Ortiz Dom's longtime
badass lover and now wife don't you just
love a furious lady fight in these films
and this one looks like it doesn't
disappoint
you gotta be kidding me
it's possible there might be a cipher
Dante team up in this film and that
would be
an worried looking kid there well that's
Dom's baby all grown up who Dom aptly
named Lil Brian otherwise known as Lil B
after his original partner in crime
Brian O'Connor hey I thought you could
leave without saying goodbye
oh but this first fast 10 trailer has us
a bit worried because we know Dante is
after blood and we're thinking he means
bloodline specifically targeting Lil B
I'm coming for you on and we know from
F9 that all Dom wants is to be a normal
family man and retire and raise Little
Brian and love his wife Letty and have
backyard barbecues and drink Coronas and
drive American Muscle Cars I mean is
that too much to ask just let him live
happily ever after people but his
estranged brother Jacob played by the
incredibly charismatic John Cena doesn't
get the memo and turns up as a power
hungry terrorist agent sick of living in
his Big Brother's Shadow forcing Dom
back into the driver's seat once again
to save the day you might want to buckle
up buckle up Indie Dom especially
because we're getting Whiplash as it
looks like John Cena's Jacob is
officially a good guy now in the second
fast 10 trailer and taking a sweet
nephew on a cannon car Joyride and
honestly thank God for Cena's Jacob
because it looks like he might offer a
bit of comic relief as he does in most
films in fast 10 because watching the
first trailer it kind of sounds like
we're gonna get emotionally punched in
the nuts that's the problem with having
such a big family how do you choose the
ones you save don't worry little B we're
a little afraid too I mean who's gonna
die in this film we may need to bring a
box of tissues because some big
characters lives feel like they're
genuinely at stake like permanently and
to make us even more nervous here's what
director Louis La Terrier said quote not
every character will make it out of fast
10 alive there's a war Brewing it's
coming to an end and it is a race to the
Finish there will be some tremendous
casualties I mean sir did you have to
use the word tremendous I mean look at
the returning characters besides these
two and a few newbies we've come to
really love this rambunctious and hard
to kill group I mean sure we love the
crazy car stunts and drag races the
villains the wild twists and turns but
it really all always comes down to these
people these characters who've really
become family and if you really think
about it there are so many a-listers in
one film that are all major characters
here is what the man himself Vin Diesel
had to say about it I don't think 20
years ago we would have ever imagined
that there would be a long line of Oscar
winners that would want to come be a
part of this mythology
and I don't and I always ask myself what
is it
that makes people
want to be a part of this mythology and
that is the beauty of a franchise this
size over this many years it feels
special and we love it other returning
characters that we're really excited to
see are shot's mom Queenie Shaw played
by the iconic Helen Mirren L from F9
played by Anna sawai Sean Boswell played
by Lucas Black buddy played by Michael
Rooker little nobody played by Scott
Eastwood and cardi b as Lisa and shout
out to our new homies Brie Larson's
making her debut as tests a rogue agent
from the agency Rita Moreno is gonna be
Dom Mia and Jacob's Abuelita Toretto
Alan richson as Ames the new agency boss
and Daniela melchior as a Brazilian
street racer from Dom's pass and
obviously Dante is new but we hope he
stays true to his name and dies Inferno
style before he causes us too much grief
you guys are going to hell now three
people who probably aren't coming back
are Kurt Russell's Mr Nobody because he
blew up but we all know that doesn't
necessarily mean he's dead in this Saga
gal gadot's Giselle cause also dead but
could be a fun surprise return for Han
and then of course Dwayne Johnson and
even though Paul Walker passed away
during the filming of Furious 7 his
character Brian is still alive in the
franchise as we saw in F9 with him
turning up for the family Barbecue in
his classic blue car we will most likely
see a tribute to him in this film
because this year marks 10 years since
the death of Paul Walker and his next
installment will include a special Cameo
from his daughter Meadow
it's never goodbye as previously
mentioned coming to the franchise is
director Louis letterier who signed on
after beloved writer director Justin Lin
parted ways now Lynn remains on board as
one of the co-writers and producers but
we're feeling good about letterier as he
notably directed the first two
transporter films Now You See Me The
Incredible Hulk and so much more and
Michelle Rodriguez recently said the
French director brought quote an energy
of love to the production and that cast
and the crew were lucky to have him and
from the trailers alone it looked like
he really clicked with this franchise
get it clicked like clicking a seatbelt
okay I will see myself out now I said
forget about it but before I go remember
there will be cars fast cars bromances
bromances black girls and families and
so my family that is everything you need
to know before you go see fast tenant
theaters May 19th I'm your host Naz
Perez and be sure to rate and review
fast 10 at rottentomatoes.com
[Music]
foreign